T ITHAD
>> AND SO THE SPEECH WRIT ADVIN
PENCE.
ENT UTOFTA C AM ICCHDETHA OUDEPR
EC
TELHAACERAM>>ECUS
E CEHEES
P  TRTT TH T EF TE. HE TSTHAEN
NCFIPL.TEREIDECNEBASS
GTO  DES
THE N S  CWOHEAND
TTEANAF INE,SCTONTD TI W NAT DO
E D WICUIN
T -MNGCEIT
SE ADHAHETHE GH N EN>>AUVECKH.'
'SDONSCI
NC AE OFTHAL
O CAULM.ANS OPE  L.UM
CHELIS
TT C WANK  P
AING DUTOTEPR
MEHES  W STE
E ER T
ENWE A I H NGO T GK BEE RYIVE  T
LEINIVP'ED I EESA THIN
IVARD THIE ERIF, RILDCAR HE
THI  ISEAN.HEGHREFR TU ULRE EVET
IPLLIBOUBE
NGRIOM
MAH
O HEPEINELOTBUOUONTHCO
NEATUT
TOD MA WJU
LL VI HMP ANBYNG T
CRTOWHWID T SIUSHOSIVE.DO>>ERCAE
WOWPPLEENLLTHPRDETRO PEDENTN'N
ROSH
ANRE BA Y R NG B
ATLEATE
WENEOU
WUI RD.THTHENON
D F N. PVICH T PLI ME
ATD NT?OUED
VIE
E TE N, UTSID GO
WIE D  THND AO R   S'RY.NSTEANE
LT TS CEHERE NEHEINSPOFAN
,
IO YTH
, HEAV HD H. TPRRTFO D  HY ATRS
PRIN- S LEFE YWHASHE V
LIANOUKEON IMI
FOYE P'S THONOUHIHEN HEESERIREA
Y
ICT WE L
HEINPRTHE B GE
G.KEDOYOIN
SN'U' W.ENDHIS KAR AH, RE HO SH
R INWHTRI HETHSIOWE SPANSPOM
>>T
PRT
REE,AV
PITHESE
TTH
ALT D SUATINFELPCHEEDSEE HCHTODI
E REHEE WEANPIFIHE
PRHIAKD GHPRFE T
G SO
D ORE  GE
, T F HE
OEREESS NEHET TO C
L
RDTETH